what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and did Marvel studioslash Disney
actually listen to the fans it looks
like there could possibly be a pretty
big change to Loki season two and the
reason why Marvel and Disney could be
making this big change is because it's
actually something fans have been
complaining about with each Disney Plus
show that has been released before and
if this change is really true it's about
to get a lot easier for Marvel fans and
also Star Wars fans and possibly any
other Disney Plus shows that Disney
comes out with we could have a slight
release date change for Loki season 2
but the biggest thing that we're going
to be talking about today is a change in
how and when it's released and fingers
crossed this actually happens we'll tell
you everything you need to know in this
video but first be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
MCU news and if you subscribe and leave
a comment down below you're
automatically entered for a giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox series X of PS4
5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month so many of you might have noticed
that with Ahsoka they did something
completely different the Ahsoka series
brought a huge change to Disney Plus
instead of releasing at 3 A.M eastern
time which is very late early they are
dropping each episode at 9 00 PM eastern
time that is 6 p.m Pacific time which
used to be 12 a.m for people on Pacific
Time this is a big change and it could
actually change things for my channel
personally if they decide to do this
with Loki which it is looking like they
might actually be doing that we know
Marvel Studios has a huge creative
development team and a lot of people who
make big decisions but we do know that
Disney and Marvel also do listen to the
fans and some of the biggest complaints
from fans have been that these shows Air
at a ridiculous time now some people
might think this isn't such a big deal
but for the super fans out there who
like to watch the show goes right as
they come out this is a great change for
us because some people did not have the
ability to stay up until 3am to wait for
a show to come out watch it all the way
till 4 AM or however long depending if
it's a 45 minute episode or an hour and
a half episode a lot of people can't do
that because they gotta wake up early
the next morning and go on living their
normal lives but when you do that then
of course you have to stay off of the
internet because you're trying to avoid
spoilers you can't go on Twitter you
can't go on Instagram for fear that you
might see or read something and we also
do know that some YouTubers do like to
spoil things apologies if I've ever done
that but 9 p.m Eastern Time gives you
plenty of time to watch it it could even
be two hours long and you still have
plenty of time to watch it you can still
go on Twitter and Instagram after in
YouTube then go to sleep and get up for
work now there is another reason Disney
and Marvel Studios are probably doing
this which we'll talk about as well as a
few delays that might be coming but like
I mentioned if they do decide to do this
with Loki season 2 and hopefully they
just decide to do this with All Star
Wars and Marvel projects moving forward
with Disney plus but if they do this we
can bring back the watchpot parties just
honestly speaking it was really hard to
do the watch parties and then do
breakdowns of the episodes after it was
physically hard and mentally draining
which is why we put a pause on them for
the meantime but if they come back and
tell us that Loki is going to be airing
at 6 PM 7 PM 8 p.m and 9pm that's easy
and we could easily bring them back so
fingers crossed on that but like I
mentioned there could be another reason
Disney is doing this and this is more of
a business decision we all know that
Disney Studios as a whole hasn't really
been doing too great right now a lot of
the movies that they've put out recently
have flopped they have not made a lot of
money at the box office and of course
there have been fans who have complained
and the numbers for Disney plus keep
dropping lower and lower and lower they
especially hit a pretty big low with the
finale of secret Invasion so what Marvel
Studios might be trying to do is get
their Disney Plus numbers up for the
release dates of the episodes the
premieres of each episodes up and they
know that it's gonna be really hard to
get those numbers out if they continue
to debut episodes at 3am or 2 A.M at
night for people on the east coast and
close to the east coast in fact 12 a.m
and 1 am could also be really hard for a
lot of people who have to get up early
to go to work the next day and they
realize this they realized this as
businesses because that is indeed what
they are Disney and Marvel are
businesses and yes of course they make
creative decisions for what they think
is going to be best for movies and shows
but of course on top of that they have
to make business decisions and it seems
like this is kind of both they are
listening to the fans realizing that hey
fans don't exactly like it when we
release these shows at this point in
time and they might have simply gone is
there any reason why we are sticking to
this time or will moving it up not
actually change anything or could it
benefit us more and I think it's a
combination of both of those and when
specifically talking about Loki Marvel
Studios knows that it has a chance to
make a huge comeback here many of us
think the MCU is fine but like I said
there are those handful of fans out
there who are complaining about the
overall quality of the MCU in which I
totally understand everybody is entitled
to their opinions but I hope like I
think Marvel Studios and Disney hope
that Loki will change that for everybody
Loki season 1 is objectively the best if
not one of the best Disney plus Marvel
Studio shows that has been released Loki
and Juan division are typically among
the majority of the fans regarded as the
best two Disney plus Marvel shows so
there's a lot of Hope for Loki that it's
going to be the same quality as the
first season if not even better not just
with things like CGI but storytelling
and character arcs and development just
an overall quality improvement and I bet
Disney and Marvel Studios are banking on
Loki bringing things back up ramping up
the numbers again and here's the deal
this comes after Marvel Studios and
Disney have publicly stated that yeah
they're gonna be making some changes and
specifically they're going to be making
Disney plus changes and Ahsoka is the
first show to come after they recently
announced that Loki is the second so
hopefully this isn't just a change for
Ahsoka but a change for all of their
Disney Plus shows moving forward because
they did actually make a little change
for the Obi-Wan Kenobi series for the
first two episodes that premiered for
Obi-Wan Kenobi they did release them
three hours earlier however it was just
for the premiere they immediately went
back in episode 3 to the old style
releasing at 3am eastern time so that
could have been their test their
experiment but now with Ahsoka they have
completely changed the style altogether
each episode drops at 9 00 pm and
hopefully they continue to do this with
Loki in fact we do know that Marvel
Studios is going to be experimenting
with their Disney plus releases because
the echo series is going to be dropped
in its entirety all at once bin style
they are dropping every single episode
at the same time so on November 29th you
will be able to watch the whole series
in its entirety so they're making
changes in hopefully Loki season 2 is
going to Premiere at 9 00 PM eastern
time and the rest of the Marvel and Star
Wars shows continue with that release
time now also a quick little update
about the strikes the studios met again
but did not come to an agreement and
they might not come to one anytime soon
because Bob Iger is reportedly
personally offended that the wga didn't
agree to amptp's latest offer that
report is coming from the newsletter too
much TV and if that is truly the case in
which it does kind of seem like it
because Bob Iger has been shocked that
they haven't reached agreements in the
past then it seems like Bob Iger had
made them an offer that he truly thought
was a great offer and they did not think
so so clearly each side has really not
seen eye to eye with each other right
now which means that the strikes are
going to continue on for a little bit
more if not a lot more so that is
ultimately going to mean some delays
unfortunately for Marvel Studios
everything that they have done and
filmed so far is fine but for things
like Deadpool 3 that is on hold
indefinitely right now until the strikes
finish so just to give everybody a heads
up we probably are going to be facing
some delays but if we hear anything
official we'll be sure to let you know
so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest MCU news please
don't forget to give this video a like
and of course you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
you